Senator Tim Scott has gone on to the
view and he's defended his position as a
republican specifically as a black
Republican and he did it pretty
successfully what is your definition of
systemic racism let me ask answer the
question that you've answered or does it
even exist in your mind let me answer
the question this way one of the things
I think about and one of the reasons why
I'm on the show is because of the
comments that were made frankly on this
show that the only way for a young
African-American kid to be successful in
this country is to be the exception and
not the role that is a dangerous
offensive disgusting message to send to
our young people today that the only way
to succeed is by being the exception Tim
Scott is not great on campaign rally
stages you might remember his campaign
announcement was not quite at a Howard
Dean level of but it was bordering on
that and he handled it as well as he
could but that's not where he shines Tim
Scott does really really well here